now presumably this tour will be its
British tour it's a British tour yeah
because you're not keen on anywhere but
there's a language barrier yes well no
I'm not great with the old language
barrier I was in Spain and I was in a
restaurant and I needed to use the
facilities in this restaurant so I
popped off and I don't to go into too
much detail but I needed to drop the
kids off at the pool so I did that I
went to flush didn't work flushed again
six seven times I tried to get it down
James would not go do the right thing
I'm not just gonna do a hit and run and
leave it here I'll go out and tell
someone that there's a problem with
their facility so I went out into the
restaurant I found the waiter
unfortunately he didn't speak a word of
English I didn't speak any Spanish so I
ended up kind of gesture - this man is a
yes can you just come here no leave the
malarious just follow me I assured him
in to the toilet
I went to flush it went down
straightaway
[Applause]
[Applause]
we flying at issue for the showroom yeah
can we get a tissue a tissue should I
made her lactate we need some weird that
you've got a box of tissues right beside
your computer home
[Laughter]
[Music]
you